African continent.
More than a fifth of its one point three
billion people don't have enough to eat.
With water shortages and extreme weather
events being the main contributing
factors.
Somalia, though, is at the epicenter of
this deepening climate and hunger crisis
that is gripping most severely the East
Africa region.
Bloomberg traveled to Gulf chaos in
central Somalia last month, where the
impact of the worst drought to impact
the country in four decades was laid
bare.
Vast tracts of countryside were
transformed into barren wasteland.
Crops had been decimated and children
were dying of starvation.
One woman named Hassan had lost five of
her 10 children to starvation and
disease within the past year.
After the drought wiped out most of her
family's goatherd, its main source of
income.
Official data shows that 900 other
children under the age of five have died
across Somalia since January.
The true tally is unknown and unlikely,
exponentially higher because vast areas
are under the control of al-Shabaab
insurgents and inaccessible to officials
and aid workers in the area surrounding
Gul Kale.
More than half of the children are
already considered malnourished
Countrywide.
More than 350000 Somalian children have
been treated for the condition this
year.
Almost half of Somalia's 17 million
people are in urgent need of aid, and
more than one million have abandoned
their homes in search of food and
grazing.
Rains have failed for five consecutive
seasons, and water shortages are even
worse than in the early 1990s, when a
famine claimed about 260000 lives.
The UN expects a famine to be declared
soon in three isolated regions of the
country.